I'm starting to feel it now oh my god hi
there I'm Aria and I love to eat
although not quite as much as the
mukbang performers who can be regularly
seen eating large quantities of food in
front of thousands upon thousands online
this phenomenon was born in Korea and
I'm thinking what better way to learn
about the art of the mukbang than by
performing one myself blowing up since
2008 book bongs feature broadcast
jockeys or BJ's who stream themselves as
they consume large portions of food
while interacting with viewers that
according to one theory eat vicariously
through them and to get the proper
experience I'm meeting with honey one of
YouTube's most popular mukbang stars
because I'm so hungry mom literally
means eating show but to me it's being a
friend to my honeybees who are my
subscribers so this is my kitchen where
I normally cook all my food for my MA
pies
what would you say is the craziest thing
you've cooked yourself the craziest
thing is mozzarella corn dogs I eat all
of them yeah some people who come to my
channel say her intro so cringy but I
love that I can be more silly and just
be myself
when I film up bungs I think about all
these ideas and then I start writing it
on the whiteboard so you guys to eat
food from all on the world
my dad always introduced me to different
types of food and that's what my
honeybees love about me because I tried
different types of food when I was
around 6 or 7 years old my dad fainted
and when we went to the hospital the
doctor said he only had six months to
live but he actually fought for 14 years
through a mukbang I tell my life story
and I get to remember my dad
and get to share all the food that I
shared with him with my honeybees so
right here is my room this is where the
magic happens yeah exactly
I've got to ask is there a sexual
element to this for some viewers I think
so a very few percentage but I think
mostly the slurping sound makes you want
to eat the food so it's not too much of
the sexual content
I think people watch muffins because
they want to make new friends that's one
reason why I started my Muslim channels
welcome bang isn't all about filming and
eating in front of the camera it's more
about helping others with depression
anxiety and being their companion having
learned more about honey's process I'm
now ready to tackle the mukbang
challenge she has arranged for me the
challenge is I'm gonna try to eat five
noodles and you're gonna try to eat five
noodles okay and see who eats it faster
a lot of people have actually tried this
so I'm surprised that you haven't ever
no you're really gonna get a major BTS
BTS booty tingling sensation you know
what I actually have a little extra
surprise for you what I say we greet
ourselves some Trinidad scorpion peppers
on top you know what I actually have a
surprise for you
I have the world's hottest chocolate Oh
we'll do the challenge mm-hmm we grate a
little bit of this on top and then we
could try this after dessert dessert
okay we're gonna boil two eggs one for
me and one for you it helps coat your
stomach before you eat anything spicy I
think it's ready so in Korea we cracked
each other's eggs can I show you
and after preparing a dish that could
easily feed and possibly kill a family
of aid the stage is set for us to begin
how many bees it's your girl honey and
this is our yeah so let's dig in because
our song gree 3 2 1 I was starting ok
but then the heat started really build
up into my mouth
ah how are you feeling ok cuz I
definitely bit into some of that peppers
I felt some of the flakes there's a
snowball eyeing white songs burning now
my lips I really feel like it was at the
point where I couldn't even put my mouth
because my lips were on fire already hey
I'm not gonna drink again I grabbed a V
and Christian Christian get in here they
jumped in how was it so usually talked
about life right mm-hmm
cool I was like you know what screw it
I'm just gonna walk down as much as I
can and that may have been a very
foolish choice Oh
because then right after that out came
that chocolate chili I'd like to
dedicate this to all the milk bangers
out there stay look muggy and it went
all downhill from there
oh no I feel you okay now it's on my
tongue I need the milk thank you for
watching this BuzzFeed video about book
ban thank you guys so much for watching
my next video bye I'd throw why don't we
do this
you taught me one of the combat you'll
be like oh they're exaggerating I think
if I had to experience a mukbang that
was the way to do it all in you have any
final thoughts about buh buh buh fine
isn't all about any in front of the
camera just having fun making new
friends that was one of the craziest
most fun experience of my life and I'm
so happy that my bunk and bring people
together I just want to keep doing it
and I want to thank all of my honeybees
for supporting me and loving me I love
you guys I would gladly do imma firin
again maybe just not this dish you know
maybe maybe just some nice mcdonald's
hit that dollar menu up McChicken let me
chicken never does this to you
let me chicken never does this to you
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part